the hottest rapper in LA right now the
trophy for sure definitely uh you got to
explain the trophy well I saw you
explain it essentially like it's like
you doing big [__] X for like you like
yeah you like a you like a joint cuz you
like a trophy cuz like a big dog big dog
status cuz you like a [__] did you see
academics uh when he got into a fight
with this girl he was like yelling like
I'm the prize no see that he was like
I'm the prize he was yelling at this
girl you know what I'm saying we should
say I'm the trophy to your [__] you
know what I'm saying like you won you're
lucky they be already knowing some of
them they be already knowing who the
trophy is they be already knowing what
is your are you like juggling multiples
right now or like how how's the how I
mean obviously things are going very
well for you right now so I'm assuming
that the attention I mean you probably
always been doing well in the ladies
department I gather oh yeah hell yeah
always had [__] cuz like a young
[__] and always had like long hair cuz
growing up so the [__] used to trying
long hair they want to braid your hair
think I was a little girl growing up
like look at the little girl they like
my son is my son's mixed and he has
really long hair yeah so anytime we go
to a restaurant they're always like what
does she want I'm
like they cut my [__] too when I was
growing up my sh have been way longer I
grew it out when I went to prison oh
[__] they cut my [__] when I was like 11
what is it about girl like girls like
guys with long hair is it cuz they they
like to braid it they like to like what
is it I know cuz I don't know probably
that they like to braid probably I don't
know I don't know that's what's up man
so but certain [__] like I don't know
certain [__] like different though
cuz certain [__] like waves certain
[__] like dreads true it's like
different [__] depends on the [__] why'
you never dread your hair hey it's funny
cuz I I started my [__] I started dreads
in prison but I a had no patience cuz
for the [__] to lock so I'm
likez let me take these [__]
out braids I feel like you get a little
more flexibility you want to take them
out you do more you do more [__] Rock
the afro ponytail braids pop someoke
braids you can do whatever you want to
do you [__] around and do look like a
whole different person in two weeks you
come out here with the afro no okay
that's how Snoop used to be in the '90s
you would see Snoop with all his braids
and then you would just think that's how
Snoop look looks and then you would see
him with the [__] like oh [__] c um so
are the are the ladies like elevating in
terms of the quality nowadays yeah hell
yeah on the dead homies cuz [__]
talking about they got all type of nurse
jobs doctor jobs I do all type of sh bus
doctors getting at you hell yeah all
type of [__] cuz they homies that got
[__] rolling I say for you the little
bunk [__] though still trying though
here and there you know the little bunk
[__] still trying to shoot their
little shot on the dead be little Buck
[__] still try you know they gonna
always try cold shoulder I mean they're
they they have a purpose right just like
some head in the back seat somewhere or
something n hell no cuz cuz cuz once you
start doing [__] like that on a day
homie you going you going to get used to
doing [__] like that like all right only
doctors are sucking your dick right now
yeah that type of [__] models spy little
[__] cuz not no little bunk [__]
cuz you going to do it one time and then
you going to get comfortable with doing
it cuz you going do it again again again
are you comfortable with um hooking up
with the girls with the only fans going
on I wouldn't make a [__] with only
fans like my main [__] but she could be
like some fun like for like yeah for
like on some fun type [__] like on like
caught up in a moment one of those
moments probably on the day homies but I
never no you can't be my if she was so
fine and she came to and she was like
that [__] don't mean nothing I want to
be your main [__] I'll delete my only
fans right now I'll delete it off the
inter it depends on what type of content
she had on there cuz some [__] got
only fans and they only showing like
feed some [__] got only fans and they
just doing like other [__] if she like
on there [__] and sucking and she's
not [__] and sucking she's just on
there [__] herself with a dildo nah
on a dead homie that's not spoy cuz
she's not with any other people still
too many people seen that
though what if she's only on H so as
long as so if the pussy's being shown
you're out yeah that's that's that's so
I was say what if she's just on there
getting her [__] ate by a
girl some girl on girl [__] and maybe
you're like yo she's like I want to go
back to the straight [__] n that's still
that's still not spoy cuz cuz it's still
like on a dead homie I don't know that's
still not that's not a good look I
respect Hey listen if she just on there
like you know doing iine with your
standards I line with your standards I'm
married as well but you know that's not
straight I don't want my [__] on the
internet getting her [__] at by no not
your main one yeah not my main [__]
yeah you have uh do you have a son or a
daughter I got a son his name trophy his
name is trophy yeah [__] great name
for a kid I'm gang he five months 5
months old shout out to Trophy what is
has fatherhood changed you at
all
uh yeah in what way yeah because like I
got to get back home to my son so
instead of like doing stupid [__] not
thinking I got to like you know I'm
living for him now so everything I do is
got to re be like for him type [__]
instead of just moving sloppy in the
streets I gotta like think about him
like I got to raise my son yeah like the
goal should always be to get back home
to your kid right yeah for sure are you
like instead of like you just kidless
and you just out here just doing
whatever like 100% And and they don't
got [__] to lose exactly are you
changing shitty diapers yeah I did a
couple times but I let his mom really
deal with that [__] mom's dealing with
the [__] yeah I know his mom deal with
that [__] I had my kid when he was a
baby shot on me on accident he was like
had diarrhea and it he pissed on me a
couple times threw up on me all the time
yeah the PUK going to happen the baby
baby milk puke yeah I'd have been h i
really put that [__] on he didn't threw
up right on it there I'm like [__] take
it off yeah it's crazy how's your how's
are you and uh his mom have a like a
healthy relationship n hell no man that
[__] toxic as a [__] bro [__] D
what's her ethnicity black she's black
okay yeah I got a Mexican baby mama
who's a psychopath yeah to her yeah she
crazy as a [__] when toxic how
though like obviously like crazy cuz she
want you f or she do crazy [__] like she
just my trigger points cuz so I be out
whatever on the de homie she just like
trigger a [__] bro for have me like off
my Square cuz homies now now was like
now I being like way better can she send
you a text and ruin your mood on the
dead that type of [__] cuz she used to
do that type of [__] she do that [__]
she'll know you're out doing some [__]
and she'll be like I'm ruin his [__]
night and then shoot you some [__] yeah
or post some stupid [__] on the dead
homies that me and her only know about
like on the dead homies post some little
stupid [__] on [__] like just dumb [__]
but yeah [__] like that though that [__]
be happen a lot send me dumb what would
be like a something you I mean you don't
have to share but something that you
could share was like a trigger of yours
where she would just [__] like put
the knife in uh when she called me a
dead beat oh that's dead homies I hate
that [__] I'll be doing it up for my son
cuz yeah and it's like you also are are
obviously you have a career that's
flourishing right now but no I made her
I made her uh make a promise cuz to
never do that [__] again yes what she
ain't been doing a lady cuz she already
know I do it up for I do whatever for
him so yeah you're supporting your kid
right yeah that just yeah yeah that just
one of them though calling me a Deb but
she got she a lot of low trigger points
like I said I've been getting better at
it now though I just ignoring her now
cuz she been getting better at like what
do she work or do she just take care of
the kid and you you yeah she work okay
okay yeah well [__] man like you know
her mom help us like we watching you
can't call somebody a dead beat bro yeah
especially if they ain't a dead
especially if they not one that [__]
just like I get it if they're a dead
beat I get it but like it's she it's cuz
she she sees what's happening she wants
to like you know yeah yeah yeah she
wants you to herself bro that too but
like you know she had it but she like
blew it on so she blew it so you guys
are not dating anymore you guys are just
no you know parenting co-parenting yeah
hey co-parenting is important especially
like listen when your kid starts to get
older she got to kill all that toxic
[__] cuz the K she straight though she
she straight on game that's good good
man she did a lot for me that's what's
up man um for you like obviously you've
had a pretty interesting 12 months but
really the last six seven months things
have really picked up for you like
um are you feeling that now are you kind
of feeling like okay because I've heard
you have a reputation that you're crazy
I don't know if you know that about
yourself that's what they say lot a
couple of people like homie's crazy he's
really like he really crazy you know
crazy I I've heard that um but I'm
wondering like for you obviously 5
months ago you have a kid your rap
career is flourishing like crazy are you
feeling like oh [__] like I really got
some like life-changing momentum that
could go you know we I mean you've seen
a lot of people get hot and go away get
hot die you know what I'm saying like um
are you kind of like feeling like
finally like oh [__] you know what this
is for real like this this rap shit's
really working out for me yeah hell yeah
lately I've been feeling like that like
I've been feeling like a real artist
lately the attention I've been getting
the type of people that been tapping in
now like hell yeah this [__] like
different who's tapped in with you that
you were like oh [__] like this is crazy
I was like oh uh estg estg who W who was
sitting in this chair and stood up and
walked off yeah yeah he stood up and got
he didn't like the fact that I was you
probably said buk what you say bro I
asked him what he thought about aliens
yeah and then I asked him about his
football career and he [__] stood up
and walked off his football career right
he was no he played football he went to
the NFL combine he was like a linebacker
at I think Eastern Kentucky was like a
like he could have went to the league
yeah he probably I don't think he W I
don't I don't know I just thought the
football thing was like a there's video
of him like [__] in press conferences
like [__] people up on the football
field so I was just asking him about it
and he's like what's that got to do with
my music and I was like but it's got a
lot it's you bro I'm asking about you
dog like you know what I'm saying like
yeah D yeah he probably yeah he wanted
to talk about SOG tapped in yeah he's
dope I love his music yeah he wants to
work yeah he told me to send him
something oh that' be hard yeah that
[__] crazy